When you want to create a fresh
libGDX Project, you can actually use
the super-convenient libGDX
Project Setup utility.
We actually included it at
the root of the course code.
It's called gdx-setup.jar.
If you want to download the setup app
for yourself, you can just search for
libgdx.
This first result's the one you want.
Select Download and
select Download Setup App.
If you get this alert saying that
gdx-setup can't be opened because it's
buy an unidentified developer,
you can fix that by opening up your
System Preferences,
going to Security and Privacy,
and checking the radio button for
Allow apps downloaded from Anywhere.
Now the setup app needs some information
to configure our new project.
We'll give it the name Icicles.
We use the package
com.udacity.gamedev.icicles.
We'll name the game class IciclesGame.
Destination is where the project setup
utility will crate your new project,
we'll just say Desktop/Icicles.
Next, the project set up
utility needs the path of
your Android software development kit.
If you don't remember where that is
you can open up the Preferences pane
of Android Studio, search for
sdk and then up in this box here
you'll find the path of your SDK.
We'll just copy that and we'll paste it
into the libGDX Project Setup utility.
Next you can select what version
of libGDX you'd like to use.
You'll almost always just
want to use the most recent.
Then you need to decide what
subprojects you want to include.
Unless you're using some particular
extension that doesn't support
all the different subprojects, you
should probably just include them all.
It's much easier to remove a platform
you don't plan to support later,
than it is to add in a new platform.
Finally, you can include
various extensions.
Box2D is included by default.
It's a super powerful
2D physics engine and
we'll end up using
that in a later course.
But uncheck that for now.
Finally, hit Generate.
42 seconds later,
we have a successful build.
Let's go load up our new project.
As usual, we open up Android Studio and
select Import Project.
We can hit this button
to jump to the desktop.
Here's the Icicles
folder we just created.
Now it looks like we're all loaded up.
Let's open up the Terminal.
And we can run the desktop run
task to see what we've got.
[LAUGH] All right, looks like
the default project just comes with
a red background and
the Bad Logic Games logo.
Awesome, now you can create
whatever new projects you want and
you don't have to rely on our starter
code in the course repository.